él es luís alberto rivas and dura y
director del banco general de la
producción banpro en nicaragua la
policía del país anunció que el banquero
fue arrestado el 15 de junio y lo acusan
de conspirar contra el estado es
investigado por realizar actos que
menoscaban la independencia la soberanía
y la autodeterminación necesitará la
injerencia extranjera en los asuntos
internos en las últimas semanas al menos
12 opositores han sido arrestados en el
marco de una nueva legislación llamada
ley de defensa de los derechos del
pueblo entre los detenidos se encuentran
incluso los guerrilleros sandinistas
dora maría téllez y hugo torres además
de cuatro candidatos a la presidencia
para las elecciones del próximo 7 de
noviembre cristiana chamorro arturo cruz
félix maradiaga y juan sebastián
chamorro
el arresto de rivas andura y ocurrió el
mismo día en que 26 de los 34 miembros
de la organización de estados américanos
oea aprobaron una resolución en la que
exigieron la liberación inmediata de los
detractores detenidos
nos recuerda a esta resolución que es
necesario recuperar la democracia y el
respeto a los derechos humanos en el
país nos recuerda que la utilización de
legislación y acciones represivas y
violentas para silenciar los medios de
prensa y la oposición se han vuelto lo
cotidiano en el país el gobierno de
daniel ortega ha dicho que este tipo de
pronunciamientos son un ataque frontal a
su soberanía y dice que está en su
derecho de investigar a los opositores